you were a child actor in the 70s and I
was thinking about that era today so
many such a kooky time in show business
especially television they had those
crazy game shows and variety shows did
you do the cookie variety shows I did oh
yeah I I mean I did all those I I I was
in a a weirdo singing group like a
really weird singing group where they
wore like orange shoes and stuff and
there were there were like an older
person and a younger person there was
probably 30 of us and we sang Little
songs and stuff and we played we were on
the sunny and share show and sunny and
share show oh my God that's a shortlived
show but memorable that was huge the
sunny and share show yeah it was a big
big deal it was huge um yeah so we sang
uh songs and stuff and then um they said
that they were going to be playing for
the White House and I was going to have
to play for Richard Nixon and my mom
like she got me out of
there your mom pulled you out like oh no
she's not singing for Richard nion and
that was the end of me and the
congregation really so you left the
group the group went on and sang for
Nixon but not you yes and Nixon was
probably there like where's Foster where
is did you you you were on The Dating
Game mean I on The Dating Game with my
mom with your mom she was the date and
she said to me you know I just don't
want Hawaii I want anywhere else but
Hawaii so I want to make sure explain to
people who don't know the the dating
game was I don't know how many people
know about it but it was like the big
game show they gave you really good
prizes of that era where we talk to
possible dates you could the woman
couldn't see the dates and would to ask
them different questions so you were
asking on behalf of your mom I was
asking on behalf of my mom so she she
tried coaching me a little bit she's
just like you know she'd tell me types
she didn't like big walrus mustache
she's like stay away from them that's
what everybody had in the 70s that's
true that's and so you were desperately
uh your mom desperately did not want the
prize to be Hawaii Hawaii yeah and of
course that's what the prize was so she
was pissed she was mad yes she was mad
you know you and Andy rter have
something in common which is you've both
done Celebrity Jeopardy oh oh yes well
the Dum Dum yes yes the Dum Dum show me
too me too um I call it yeah it's it's
it's yeah you didn't say that Andy when
you came back Andy when you came back
you said it was the challenge of your
life you were sweating well that's why
whenever anybody anybody is
congratulatory about Jeopardy it is
really it's it is really dumb down for
us yes and that was fine by me because I
wanted to win the problem was is I
couldn't uh my there's something with my
thumbs and I couldn't get you know the
guys I was doing this but I just never
got on it is it is an athletic
competition for your thumb for your
thumb because it really is like you do
have to if you don't get the buzzer
right you're screwed yeah yeah no I've
never because people say that all the
time that meaning that you can have you
can know the answer and hit the but hit
the button but it doesn't work happens
it yeah nothing happens so I I failed
miserably at that but then I got the
question at the end and then I won was
that of all the achievements in life is
that the greatest I think so I do I
think so